well if you're trying to buy a home
right here in las vegas right now most
likely you're frustrated as houses are
selling within
hours of being listed and offers are way
above listing price
so who is buying all these homes and in
many instances paying cash
sally jeremiah joins us live in
silverado ranchon area where many want
to live with that
answer tough for buyers right now sally
brian i'm your silverado ranch and
ourville where you can see
a whole lot of construction behind me
and realtors tell me it's people from
california who want to move here
what we're dealing with is a shortage of
inventory rob piston is an investor
owner and real estate agent for keller
williams vip
he says that shortage of inventory is
causing competition for homes
and prices to rise the housing market is
no doubt
very hot right now in my 20 years i've
never seen the inventory at this low of
a level piston believes it will continue
to be a strong market through the
end of the year i can't even keep up
with it you know i drive around town and
every corner is being built on no state
income tax and our weather
makes las vegas an inviting place to
live
we're over bidding here yes it is
happening especially with the nicer
properties
marack kaminetsky recently bought a home
he says it was very challenging
we were looking for about three months
to find
something that not only were life but
wasn't already under contract by
the time we got around to put an offer
to it and offers are
abundant for the hot properties causing
bidding wars
most of the time we weren't the highest
we were
under bid by 10 000 on the house uh we
didn't get it obviously because it was a
cash offer
but after putting in five offers he got
a home his advice
if you see something act quickly i would
say count
at least 10 to 15 more than what the
listing goes for
the prices do concern buyers concerned
of a repeat
of the great recession i worked through
2008
and that was a completely different
dynamic and in my opinion i don't think
we'll see that come back again
advise be patient and for those
first-time home buyers
you might want to consider an older home
reporting live sally jaramillo 8 news
now